Nikola Tesla, um, you guys getting
a bit of a popular revival, um,
imparts as we were mentioning.
Um, it's because your boss, um,
not long ago refer to him as a hero.
Everybody's thinking, oh my gosh,
if Larry Page thinks he's a hero,
maybe we need to learn a little bit more.
And then suddenly Elon Musk decides that
he's got a car company and you know,
a, a, a car that's named after this
character. So, um, who the heck is he?
There's sort of two broad categories of
at least those folks that sort of know
something about him.
At least my experience is one says that
he's the superman that has provided us
these amazing inventions
that underlying our economy.
The other side says that he's
kind of quirky. Like he's
an odd character. I mean,
he, you know, upper whores
jewelry, he gets a fever,
or if he looks at a peach,
he counts his steps as he walks in.
If they're not divisible by three,
he has to go back and do as
an whole journey again. Um,
so that you've got this sort of contrast.
But I guess what I want to do for,
you know, maybe about
20, 25 minutes or so,
I always talk a bit about
some observations that I
came up with in the course of
doing the research. Things that sort
of surprised me. That may surprise you.
Hopefully a, and then I'd welcome having
actually just having a dialogue, um,
answering some questions about
what you want to know, um, or no,
uh, about this, uh,
remarkable individual. Um,
so let me start with just,
um, my first observation,
I was unaware of the extent of his genius.
This man got 300 patents. Uh,
he invented the electric motor.
He invented long distance electricity
transmission according to the United
States Supreme Court. He provided
us the, uh, the basics of radio.
He did remote control. He did
robots. I mean, the list goes on. Um,
according to the American Institute of
Electrical engineers were we to seize and
eliminate from our industrial world.
The result of Mr Tesla's work,
the wheels of industry would cease
to turn. Our towns would be dark.
And that's not all long after his death.
His visions inspired great minds.
I mean,
he foresaw cell phones, radar laser
weapons, artificial intelligence,
vertical lift airplanes, cell phones, for
instance. It's guys about 110 years ago,
he's talking about a device that
can provide news, um, and you know,
stock prices and all sorts of information.
And he said,
we shall see and hear one another as
perfectly as though we were face to face
despite innovating distances
of thousands of miles.
A man will be able to carry one
and his vest pocket 110 years ago.
He had invented, but he sort
of thought about it. Um,
and that envisioning is
I think quite amazing.
He does come across as
a bit of a magician. Um,
he would do presentations at various
universities and he would admit that
electricity is this force that even
physicists will admit they don't fully
understand what it is. Um, but we,
he was an others as well.
We're able to capture it and utilize it.
And in fact,
last century you asked engineers as to
what was the major accomplishment of the
20th century. They ignored inner,
the internal combustion engine,
the computer chip,
all these other sorts of things.
They said the most amazing thing was
the ability to capture and transmit
electric power. And this man, this
magician, uh, was one of those.
He created lightning. This was something
that had been reserved only for nature,
but he's zapped it all over the place. Um,
you know, hundreds and hundreds of feet.
He also made lamps glow.
They were not attached to wires.
Um, so this man, um,
was in fact a magician.
But you should also recognize that
he had some quixotic notions that,
um, complicated as legacy or, um,
made him more interesting depending
upon your perspective. Uh,
he spent a lot of time trying to figure
out how to communicate with intelligent
beings on other planets.
He spent a lot of time trying to figure
out how to read your mind by putting
little monitors on near your retina.
Um,
so he was both practical as far
as coming up with if you will,
systems,
uh,
he was a visionary and thinking about
new things that he couldn't actually make
cause the equipment or,
um,
technology just wasn't there and he was
also a little weird and off sometimes.
And I think it's that combination
that makes him so interesting.
The second surprise for me, uh, as was
noted, um, I'm an environmentalist.
I run the Midwest Office of
the Environmental Defense
Fund working on clean
energy issues. And so for me to
find out that, uh, Nikola Tesla,
not only did he invent the electric motor,
but he also was a clean energy pioneer.
That to me was pretty exciting.
Um, and he remains an inspiration
I think to a variety of, you know,
solar and battery manufacturers.
The Elon Musk who we mentioned before
has his car and his company named after
him,
but he contributed $1 million to
revitalize the Tesla laboratory up on long
island.
Um,
I actually work in a shared office space.
It's a sort of a startup incubator and
there is right 10 feet behind my desk.
There is a full sized cutout of Nikola
Tesla that at least I used to tell my
wife, it was haunting me from behind
to go home and write more. Um,
but he has his leadership on clean
energy began actually in 1900.
Um, about 118 years ago. He
published an article in the century,
which then was the nation's largest
circulation periodical. It was entitled,
the problem of increasing human energy
with special references to the harnessing
of the sun's energy. Again, published
118 years ago was probably the earliest,
most detailed look at how to capture
power from the sun and the wind for me as
a, uh, an environmental advocate, um,
he inspires me to think of
if he was here today, what,
how great it would be to focus
on the electricity industry,
which he helped start.
But today largely because it
is monopolized. In other words,
the electric utilities have total
control as many states over both the
generation and the
delivery of electricity.
This industry has become innovation
averse has become risk adverse and it's
become stodgy is become frayed.
The list goes on.
If in fact Tesla was around,
he'd be off thinking about how am
I going to send power wirelessly,
how I'm going to make it without um,
having pollution. How am I going to
electrify other sectors of the economy,
particularly transportation.
How am I going to bring drudgery,
saving electric power to everyone?
Around the world,
perhaps for free,
including that we have 2 billion people
on this planet that do not have access
to electricity at this
moment. He, in my mind, um,
if he were with us today would be
thinking outside of the box, um,
away from the sort of the monopoly think
that currently degrades that industry.
My third surprise,
um,
was his constant attempt and need to
balance the present and the future.
Uh, call it apocryphal, call
it weird color appropriate,
but he was born during a giant
lightening storm exactly at the stroke of
midnight between the ninth
and 10th of July, 1856.
That's weird enough.
Just in the midst of a gale.
And this became part of Tesla Lore. You
know, his family sort of thought this was,
you know, this is how
look a bit, um, you know,
and he I think thought he was kind of
special because he had this trait that he
was born at this weird time
for me as a biographer,
I was able to get the
sense that in fact, um, it,
the birth story sort of
figuratively placed him in
the present as well as in the
future.
It both today and tomorrow.
And I think he spent his life trying to
struggle to find this balance between
focusing on current realities and
envisioning the future, the unknown.
And consider,
for example,
the year 1,897 he had just figured out
how to transmit the enormous power from
Niagara Falls,
um,
26 miles all the way to buffalo and then
a total of 400 miles down to New York
City. This is huge because the
technology that on Thomas Edison,
who everybody looks towards of thinking
he was the electrical genius. He however,
favored direct current, which could
basically move maybe half a mile,
maybe a mile if you're lucky.
Tesla was able to move
this power 400 miles,
the New York Times referred to this
diag or a project as the unrivaled
engineering triumph of the 19th century.
And who did the paper give credit to?
They said to Tesla belongs the undisputed
honor of being the man whose work made
this Niagara Project possible.
And of course there are statutes to or my
both sides, Canadian, the United States.
He did this amazing thing.
He was praised by the Times at parties,
et cetera. And he was bored.
This was too much today.
He had done this,
he needed to look towards the future
to create a new area of science.
And he called this tell him autonics
or what we might call a robotics.
His initial project was a radio
controlled model boat measured about,
Oh, I dunno, four feet in length
and maybe about three feet high. Um,
and he,
although he was rather shy scientist,
he was capable of being a
showman if he had to. Um,
and so he had the debut of this Tele
Matan at the Madison Square Garden.
Huge arena.
This is the old one.
But this is where it happened during
the electrical exposition in May,
1898,
remember,
this is about two months after the
battleship Maine had blown up in Havana
harbor. We were in the midst of just the
beginning of the Spanish American war.
So there was a lot of interest in
trying to figure out can we develop new
weapons. And so here comes
tests. He has this model boat.
He builds a pond in the middle of the
exhibition hall and he invites possible
investors, reporters, um,
other inventors and scientists.
And He tantalized them for,
you know, 15 or 20 minutes.
He moved the boat backwards and
forwards around the pond. Uh,
he made a dance almost like a water bug.
Um,
and so everybody was mesmerized by this.
You know, some people were thinking,
there's a tiny monkey in there. I'm
sure there's a tiny monkey in there. Uh,
but then after a while he then turns
to the audience and says, all right,
who wants to ask the a question?
Everybody's thinking.
You don't ask boats
questions, you know, some, um,
probably future Google person
came up and said, all right,
what's the cube root of 64 and Tesla,
you know,
where this hand hidden on
a lever underneath the,
the panel arranges to flick the
lights on the boat four times a.
And he said,
uh,
he created a sensation such as no other
invention of mine has ever produced.
His success of this was further
highlighted by Mark County's failure.
Remember Marconi as the one who's given
public credit for wireless transmissions.
But of about three months later,
Mark County tried to do a very
similar project, built his own pond.
He built a,
um,
a model frigate that he was to guide over
to what was referred to as the Spanish
boat and it would have little bombs
on it would blow the, you know,
the tiny little Spanish boat
to smithereens. Unfortunately,
Marconi had not mastered how does
send individualized messages.
So when his assistant punched the button,
the Spanish ship was just fine,
but there was a loud explosion to the
back room where mark had kept as miniature
bombs.
Uh,
because that's where the signal when he
hadn't figured out how to get it to the
right spot.
Uh,
and so there were loud blasts and smoke
that went throughout the exhibition hall.
Not surprisingly, Tesla was never
satisfied with just, you know,
a model boat and to the navy.
He was not satisfied to suggest this was
a submarine that would carry bombs to
blow up a frigate that was kind of boring.
You know,
they're thinking it's a Spanish
American war. This is great,
but he thinks this is a new
non biological form of life.
This is a machine that is
embodied with a borrowed mind.
His mind of course happens to be his,
um,
but he's seeing artificial intelligence
and it's predicting that this Tele Matan
not only would quote follow a course
laid out or obey commands given form in
advance,
but it will be be capable
of distinguishing between
what it ought and what it
not ought to do. This again, over
a hundred, some odd years ago,
we were beginning to think in his
mind about artificial intelligence.
My fourth surprise actually.
And so I was telling Richard Di resulted
from the discovery at the library of
Congress,
a boxes of letters that either Tesla had
written or had been written to him by
friends or colleagues at central. For a
biographer, it's perspective. This is like
Manna from heaven unit.
Suddenly you get to see this man's voice,
uh, in real time. What
those letters showed,
I think was an overlooked side
to this remarkable genius.
As I mentioned at the beginning,
you've got the school of people
who think that he was a superman,
that one biographer called him a Supernova
in the galaxy of the human race and
no doubt the combination of electric
motors, robots, remote control, you know,
radio,
these are all super accomplishments.
I'm not taking anything away from that,
but this scientist was also
human and charmingly. So,
and that was the fun part to sort
of get behind and tell that story.
His closest friends were the Johnsons.
Uh,
Robert who edited the Century magazine,
which I mentioned before,
was the largest circulation
periodical. And his wife Catherine, um,
they operate in an intellectual salon
at their townhouse in Manhattan's Murray
Hill neighborhood.
They were not particularly rich,
but they sort of acted that way
and they gathered around them,
this cadre of writers,
artists and sculptors and would have
them over for all these great dinner
conversations.
Mark Twain came to most of these and he
and Nikola Tesla became great friends.
This is Mr Twain and Tesla. There
is in the, uh, in the background.
So he would come to Tesla's laboratory
and the two of them would just play.
They'd send electrical sparks across
the room. They hold up, you know,
Globes that were unconnected
to wires and make them
glow.
They would ex-ray each other's hands.
There were two kids having a
great time in their laboratory.
They just happen to be the genius,
the engineering genius of the time,
and perhaps are the
best writer at our time.
One cute story about this is
that when they first met a Tesla,
a recalled that when he was 14 years old,
he had been quite sick and his parents
had given him some mark Twain's novels,
at least according to Tesla.
He told Mark Twain this,
that you saved my life because
I got through this sickness.
And then Tesla said,
commented upon Twain. He said,
this great man of laughter
broke out into tears.
I just thought that was so cute. Um, so
the two of them were, you know, a pair.
But I think this relationship that Tesla
had with both Robert and Catherine,
um,
reveal sort of a jovial and relaxed
sign to this usually intense,
um, in venture. They
exchanged almost daily notes.
They were talking about their health,
the writings of other scientists,
Tesla's latest inventions, um,
the state of the Johnson kids.
Um,
just to give you one sense of one letter,
when Tesla had had a cold for
a little while, uh, Robert
wrote to him and he said,
it's been a whole week since we saw you,
and you need cheering up,
coming as early as
possible and get cheered.
We're in a jolly mood and the fire is
light and on the heart and we only need
you.
So here's this unbelievably intense
inventor who really love to spend most of
his time by himself in his lab.
He was human charmingly so
would be my observation.
He never married.
He did fall in love once with a woman.
Not that I never found out. Her last
name is Ana, a supposedly beautiful eyes.
And the two of them, when he was 23 years
old, they would walk through, you know,
Austrian parks and you know,
plan how they were going to
have a big family and um,
he was going to go off to engineering
school. That did not happen.
He went off to engineering school.
The relationship did not pursue,
but he later would admit that
inventors are not to be intimate.
That was sort of his conclusion. He
said, you know, you can be a musician,
you can be an artist,
you can be all these sorts of things,
but if you're an inventor,
you're too intense.
And if you become married,
that will take away from the intensity
and focus that you need to have.
And there was one sad note near the
end of his life and he says, yeah,
that may be true, but it
also makes those lonely. Um,
so this very human scientist,
um,
I think also give us lessons about the
role and the example of being a discover.
And in inventor he reveled most
in the excitement of discovery.
Um, I just have a few pictures
of him going, you know,
sort of going through his life.
He would say,
I do not think there is any thrill that
can go through the human heart like that
felt by the inventor as he
see some creation of the
brain unfolding to success.
Such emotions make a man forget
food, sleep, friends love everything.
So where did this come from?
Where did this inventing spirit come from?
Some has to be just a Nate.
The guy was bright.
I mean he could speak
eight languages fluently.
He could recite lengthy poems
and stories just from memory.
He also had a father who was a Serbian
Orthodox priest who gave him mental
exercises. He had to remember
sequences of numbers. He had to,
you know, recite longs, um, stories
and sort of the list goes on.
Um, he also, um, was a little strange.
Um, this man who was born during
a midnight lightening storm,
uh,
when he was young,
used to have strobing light flashes in
his brain that led him to admit that
sometimes he couldn't tell the difference
between reality and something that was
fake. It also sort of led him to go off
on journeys, mental journeys, you know,
so we had daytime and nighttime sort of
dreams where he would travel around the
world to new lands, meet new people who
were almost, you know, real friends,
you know, to him. So where
did it come from? Exercise,
natural brilliance,
that a little bit of strangeness I think,
but that's probably true of all of us.
Not that yours truly has a genius, but it,
it is that combination.
He however,
had a particular type of invention
that I think is somewhat missing today.
Um,
and that's unfortunate.
His was a curiosity driven quest
for discovery or for reinvention.
And it was motivated by idealism.
And this is in contrast to Thomas Edison
who basically invented because he was
an entrepreneur and you want it to
make money and nothing wrong with that.
But Tesla,
although he certainly enjoyed his fancy
dinners at the DELMONICO's and he had a
nice apartment at the Waldorf Astoria,
but he said the technology
transcended the marketplace.
That invention should not
just be tied to profits.
He wrote the desire that guides me in
all I do is the desire to harness the
forces of nature to
the service of mankind.
So what does this teach
us? Um, if you will,
about his inventing style that
we might utilize, uh, today.
Um,
one observation,
two one is that he firmly demonstrated
the link between a love of humanities and
the love of science. Um, he loved poetry,
would recite it at length,
was deeply into, as I said,
foreign languages and foreign
literature, et Cetera. Uh,
and to give you an example,
he envisioned his revolutionary
electric motor. The make,
the thing that made the electricity
industry possible. He envisioned it.
While walking through a Budapest Park,
quoting goodness Faust and then he picked
up a stick and drew a little design of
it in the CNT.
It's this mix of humanities and science
that I think we are somewhat missing.
Uh,
today we separate them more than I
guess Tesla would argue as necessary.
The other observation and sort
of my final one is that, um,
he would observe, I think, um,
that we have moved too far away from
the individualization of the inventor or
the discover.
We now do things with teams,
and this is not a knock at all on teams,
but a lot of inventing,
as you probably know, you have your own
teams here. Um, there are teams, you know,
at universities, research centers, you
know, corporate laboratories, et Cetera,
and they worked marvelously.
But what's missing,
um,
he would argue is that sometimes you
just need the isolated individual who's
free enough to go out there
and be stupid and I'm alone.
That's not to say it. See,
he needed to balance, again,
this envisioning individualized
and venting with some reality.
And he did that largely because he had
at least for a brief period of his life,
a lawyer who kept him in check
and he needed that. So I mean,
it's not like you just have
some individual Wacko out
there just thinking about
the future.
You do need a team if you will,
but he would argue you don't need as big
of teams as we currently mostly focused
on. I don't know if that's true. I'd
welcome your insights on that one.
But that would be my guess of what
he would, um, come out. This he,
Mike, my final comment is that
I think he aimed high heat,
perhaps higher than any other inventor.
Um,
just a few more shots of him.
He worked tirelessly to bring electric
power freely to the world and he built
robots that he thought would
reduce life's drudgery.
He was in short of driven by inner
forces that made sheer creation the most
important thing in his life.
And we are the better for it.
Thank you very much.
I hope you enjoy rom reading
about this mastermind.
Um, and, um, I also hope that, uh,
you help give him more of the due
recognition that at least I and your boss
thinks that he deserves. So I'm
happy to take a few questions. Um,
there are books that are available
for all the people that are here,
but let's unwelcome some questions and
some dialogue where you want to know or
what do you know? I'll start
off with one. Oh, good.
How did he end up, what's the,
what's the end of the story? Um,
he ended up, uh, pouring
alone, um, and then, um,
lift his final days. I'm
sort of isolated, um,
and the hotel New Yorker Morgan who refuse
to see anyone and would restrict the
maids and others from actually spending
much time with them and just throws,
shoving his grool, uh, to him.
And the only reason that he
even had enough money, um,
at the end was because some sciences
out the Westinghouse Corporation,
which he essentially made possible
because he formed this partnership with
George Westinghouse to do
the Niagara Falls project.
And so Westinghouse bought initially
his patents for his electric motor.
Um,
but at the end it was a few scientists
at the Westinghouse Corporation that
convinced the corporation that it was
an embarrassment to their company,
that he had just declared bankruptcy
and they needed to give him enough of a
stipend so that at least he could survive.
Now that said he died,
I forget the room number
in the hotel New Yorker,
but it was divisible by very good of a,
and more than 2000 people then attended
his funeral service at the Cathedral of
Saint John The divine in New York
study by Columbia University.
Thank you so much for coming today.
It's really nice to see someone speak
without a teleprompter here at Google.
Most people use it, but it's
nice when it's natural. Um,
so my question is, you know, you, you
told this story about when he was born,
um,
how much do you think someone's success
is based on what they believe they can
do throughout their life? Mm. Um,
versus their natural born,
you know, intelligence.
Well, this is a tough
one for Nicola. Um, yeah,
and this is probably a longer answer
than you wanted, but his life, um,
his early life, I'm until he was
about seven years old, was blissful.
You two older sisters that doted on him,
lived on a farm, having a great time.
But when he was seven years old,
his older brother Dane who
was done I think 12 or 13,
and he was Nicholas idle
and was the family favorite,
was considered gifted beyond all means.
And he would follow his father
into the priesthood. Unfortunately,
the families, fam, um, white stallion, uh,
Bolton and through his brother to the
ground and he died that night from his
injuries and Nicola, their
witness. This, I mean,
so this was a real
changing event in his life.
Where this comes back to your comment is
that you would think his parents would
then say, oh, we've got our
remaining son. Let's focus on him.
But no, his mom and dad are thinking, oh,
if only Dane had lived, he would
have been great. Think of thing,
amazing accomplishments
that he would have hand.
So Nicola claims that he grew up
without any sense of confidence because
anything he did that was noteworthy,
his parents would think, oh,
Dane might've done it better.
So he,
he had this constant struggle
to find his father's affection.
Um, and it never came. Um, in fact, he,
this was far more than your question,
don't want wanted, but I mean,
he ended up finally getting his father
to allow him to go to engineering school
and he did it for two years and
got stellar marks. But you know,
whenever we got stellar marks,
his father was still,
oh Dane could have been better.
And so he drops out of school,
Nikola Tesla drops out of school,
take some gambling and billiards, um,
move secretly to a town
like 200 miles away,
gets arrested for vagrancy and is brought
back by the police to his parents.
You can imagine they're not exactly happy.
And I'm not suggesting this as the model
for going to, you know, Google, you know,
tenure, but, and his father died not
long after that, just from the shock.
So I don't know that,
I mean,
he's not an example of someone who was
told all your life, you are the greatest.
He was told that he was not the greatest,
and yet he persevered.
And in part he persevered in response
to his father trying to get his father's
attention. Um, you know,
and he said that he went through
the strobing intense light, um,
dreams that he had were in part
sort of a response to, you know,
this father figure. But no, he did
not grow up with confidence. Um,
it was actually quite the opposite.
Tesla,
and as we were discussing as a bit of
a cult figure in odd ways and actually
turns up in popular culture, um, he's, uh,
shows up in some movies and
some like a historical fashion.
What's your, what's
your take on that? How w
the thing that amazes me is
that as I wrote this book, um,
my publicist,
um,
posted a small excerpt of
it on a Nikola Tesla club.
Um,
I think it was based in Chicago.
And then suddenly the Nikola Tesla Club
in Toronto picked it up and then there
was a Nikola Tesla Club in Minneapolis.
There are hundreds of these
things and they're fervent, um,
followers of the man.
I mean,
so the dialogue that goes back
and forth on, um, you know,
whether what I wrote was halfway true,
where there new theory of some conspiracy
there was associated with, you know,
his final days and whether he in fact
did do a death beam and the CIA has,
you know, has um, you know,
squashed it. Um, I mean,
so yes, he has a cult following,
um, in the movie. I mean,
the perfect person played him
in one, uh, movie. David Bowie.
Is that not great? I mean, David
Bowie and Nikola Tesla, um, so, and,
and yes, they were not exactly
accurate in their depictions.
They had this one scene where Tesla's
one dream was that he was going to send
electricity into the earth, the burst
of the lightening artificial lightening,
if you will,
into the earth and take advantage of
what he felt was the earth's natural
electrical charge.
And also take advantage of resonance
or an echo of force so that he can have
this charge go throughout the planet
and people could basically, you know,
plug something into the earth
and have free power essentially.
Well, in this movie it's really
quite great. I mean, the, the,
the stars are out there.
They're screwing a light bulbs.
I like hundreds of them across this
field. Um, that did not happen.
Okay. But he has, he does
have indeed a cult following.
And I think, you know, I, I think
it's fair because I think it's impart,
um, he hasn't received
the recognition that, um,
say Edison or Morricone have an,
this is not any knock on,
on those great inventors,
but, um, you know,
the New York Times in their obituary
basically said that it was Tesla who was
the inventor of radio when I was Tesla
who brought us the electric motor and
electricity transmission.
And I don't think most people recognize
that and give him his dues. So,
um,
if that necessitates also having
kind of the weirdness involved.
Okay. What other questions? What else?
Yeah,
please.
Hi. So I was really curious
about you saying that he
died poor and he's like this
great inventor and I wanted
to know what you owe. I mean,
what did he feel about being rewarded,
at least monetarily forward
this passion that he had. Um,
and also you, yourself as
an item, writers in general,
also things such hard workers
and not being remunerated.
Oh, is that the truth? Um,
I'm not exactly answering your question,
but let me,
let me try an angle and you
can tell me if I got there.
He actually could have been
amazingly wealthy. I mean,
when he sold his electric motor
patterns to George Westinghouse,
he was living high on the hog.
As I said,
he was eating his meals at Delmonico's
every night. Foyerman Yawn. You know,
he lived in a large apartment
at the Waldorf historian,
probably the best hotel in New York
City. Oh, he got tons of money.
But Westinghouse,
um,
in large part because JP Morgan,
the banker who was not exactly
a nice man, he wasn't, um,
you know, tried to squeeze
out George Westinghouse, um,
not long after the Niagara
Project, which is, you know,
they obviously spend a lot
of money to make this happen.
And so there were a little cash short
and the economy is sort of just does it
cycles.
And this was in one of the cycles.
So Westinghouse was in not great shape
and JP Morgan basically tried to squeeze
them out and said, you know, um,
I'm gonna you either cut
expenses immensely or you know,
you give your company that me and I'll
create the total electricity trust just
like what he did with the steel industry.
So Westinghouse goes to a Tesla and says,
I'm in a real jam here.
You know, I'm about to lose my
company and you have this royalty,
$2 and 50 cents per horsepower of motor.
I can't afford it.
Tesla sitting there, he has all
the cards. He asked the patent,
he asked the contract and he's
not a really good businessman.
So he turns to George,
Westinghouse. And says,
Oh, you've been nice to me, will you?
You're the one who will bring
my electric motor to the world.
I'm willing to tear up my contract.
He tore up $1 billion of money
that would have come his way,
simply number one.
I don't think it was a great business man,
and he certainly was a
horrible negotiator, but
because he was an idealist,
here was a man who was going
to bring his invention,
which he thought was the greatest thing
in the world and not going to argue with
that.
Um,
and for that he was willing to
sacrifice an amazing amount of wealth.
Um, I'm not sure if that answered your
question, but I liked that story better.
What the lawyer had died
about a year before.
I know this is what you need a
lawyer are so many times you don't,
but this time you did.
What other questions?
Yeah.
Yes,
please.
Hi, thanks very much. And I just
wondering if you ran into, um,
any associations of Tesla with, uh, the
Boston area at all during your research?
Are there is a, um, there's
a Tesla AV in Medford.
Overbuy Tufts and I've heard stories
that he used to live over there. So
I don't know that he lived here. There is
a very interesting, um, MIT connection.
Um,
I probably said Zach,
so in his later years, um, when he was on,
to be honest, a little bit senile,
but also had flashes of genius,
he would have birthday parties for himself
and he'd invite reporters and really
50 of the major reporters from the
New York Times, The New York Herald,
Pi magazine,
all these people would come and sit at
his feet for like five hours as the great
man would ramble on 90% of the time
about jibberish and 10% of the time about
something. Oh my God. You know. So, um,
one of his visions during
these birthday parties was a,
um, uh, death beam,
something like star wars that could zap
battleships in airplanes out of the air.
All right,
we're talking in the early 1940s.
I'm at a time when we're about to go
to war and the thought of Nikola Tesla
dying and he had the designs
possibly for a death beam,
um,
did not make the Federal
Bureau of Investigation all
that excited about allowing
his papers to go anywhere in the world.
So they hired an MIT physicist
and assembled all of his papers,
you know, together, um, which were huge
boxes and he spent at least a week,
if not a couple of weeks,
oh,
I'm being overseen by Naval Intelligence
and federal FBI agents as he went
through the documents.
And there was one that he actually put
the top secret clearance on because it
was in his mind close enough,
um,
to being practical,
that it needed to be considered
to be top secret. The rest of it,
he says basically the ramblings of an
old man and like say that the only old,
but, um, but here's, here's
the critical question.
Does anybody know who the MIT professor
was that they hired to do this?
John Trump. John Trump was a member of
the National Academy of Engineering.
He won the National Academy of Sciences
Award. He also happens to be the uncle,
the 45th president of the United States.
Okay.
How's that?
And in fact,
when the current president United
States was running for office,
he would refer to his uncle
as somebody really bright.
Notice that I have a lot of smart genes.
I'm really bright and it's because that's
my only sort Boston connection through
MIT. Um, once through Mr.
Trump. What other questions?
So, uh, what brought them
from Australia to the u s um,
he came, um, because um,
he had been installing Edison
phone systems in Budapest,
in Paris. Um, to be honest,
he had been spending most of his time
thinking about electricity and in the
Budapest park envisioned the,
the engine.
But he had done such a great
job that his supervisors, um,
sent him to New York to actually work
with Thomas Edison himself. And um,
they sent him with probably the greatest
letter of recommendation that's ever
been written. They said to Thomas
Edison, this letter to Thomas Edison,
I know of two great men. You are one of
them. And this young man is the other.
So
they worked together actually,
but they were totally
different temperaments.
Mean Edison was frumpy. He was
crass. I mean, he was a genius.
I'm not, you know, this is no knock on
him. He just sort of was Tesla, you know,
was this immaculate leader,
um,
refined cosmopolitan that spoke eight
languages, new literature fluently,
um, you know, and looked like he dressed
like he was ready to go to the opera,
you know, during the day. Um, so
the two of them just, you know,
they were different sort of characters
and they've argued vehemently about how
to transmit power.
I mean,
Edison wanted to do it through direct
current because he thought it was number
one. His, um,
and safer was his biggest argument
and Tesla was far more interested in,
in trying to send it long distances so
that more people could take advantage of
it. Um, and in fact, um, this
is more than your question was,
but they split, um, because, um,
Edison refuse to provide
the promised bonus.
Um,
if Tesla would increase the efficiency
of one of the dynamos regenerators and
Tesla had worked like three months, you
know, to triple the output of this thing.
Then he goes to the wizard of Menlo Park,
who he still idolized at this time.
And Edison basically just mocked
him and said, oh, come on.
That was a joke. And then, you know,
to this young immigrant who is still a
little sensitive or being in the United
States, he says, you're such an
immigrant. If you were only an American,
you'd appreciate an American joke.
Edison, of course, to not laugh.
He pulled out his bowler
hat appropriately so,
and walked out and quit his job
and started his own company.
So that's how we got to the United States.
All right. Thank you very much again.
Thank you. I appreciate you guys having
me and I hope you enjoy the book.